and you know what there's another wild
card out there we talk about complete
teams we talk about teams that may have
needs
antonio brown's a week and a half away
from being available whoa
and i just wonder
i wonder
who's going to make that play who's
going to do it for
reasons that are he makes us better
who's going to consider doing it for
he's going to make that team held a lot
better i'd rather get him on our team
instead oh i i i mean listen
he's still
you know yeah we'll see where it goes
but i i wouldn't like think like antonio
brown's physical abilities falling off a
cliff or anything not to say i'm
expecting the superstar we saw two years
ago or anything like that but
you know if a team wanted to take that
chance
he's certainly going to help your
football team as far as what he can do
on the field and then you know there's
there's teams again like we've talked
about
where
out of these top five out of these top
six teams you know the seahawks they got
to be like all right well yeah okay can
our defense really get that much better
or we should we just go all in on
offense and make another play for a
receiver and just go we're down to go 40
37 every game we don't care you know
that's hey antonio brown julio jones aj
green if i'm the seahawks the ravens the
packers right now i am looking at those
guys to see can i get a trade done to
get those guys because i feel like i'm
in a super bowl team and i just need
that one other player to kind of put us
over the hump there i i think that's
going to be interesting to watch here in
the next few weeks
and last year the seahawks reportedly
were looking at antonio brown at the
time that they signed josh gordon and
they still have josh gordon he's just
not cleared to play you have to wonder
are the seahawks thinking about it and
that's where it becomes
three-dimensional chess because if the
seahawks are looking at this possibility
and it makes them better and you know
tom brady wants antonio brown in tampa
and and bruce arians doesn't
and they they've got a great array of
receivers
but if they're not healthy
right yeah then how do you make the
argument we shouldn't have antonio brown
if i'm tom brady i'm like hey bruce i
understand that you've got mike evans
and chris goblin and scotty miller and
and and and we've got gronk and but
every week
one of these guys isn't isn't healthy i
think bruce is never injured yeah that's
uh well he scarred from two years with
antonio brown exactly and probably the
other horror stories he heard from
pittsburgh steelers coaches after he
left and all that to where i think he's
so he's heard so many things he's
probably like i'm not dealing with that
but but you know but you know what maybe
bruce arians can be worn down if he says
hey tom
you're responsible for him yeah that
good work
we'll go get him but he's he's your
responsibility and if it doesn't work
it's on you and you're going to be the
one who has to go tell him get the hell
out of here yeah you have to keep him in
line and if you don't you have to tell
him see you later yeah and listen tom
tom could probably pull that off tom is
amazing with the team he really is you
know he's he's got special leadership
qualities you know that he really does
and he's found he's obviously bonded
with antonio brown yeah get him there
put him up in like one of the suites in
the jeter household there on hillsboro
bay and here we go
but but it but it is it is i think uh
intriguing to consider
th that mindset you know did the saints
get back in it they brought him in for a
workout last year right is is he a guy
that helps their offense do the packers
take a look at him is aaron rodgers
banging on the door saying hey one of
these other teams is going to sign this
guy i really do think the nfc teams
they're the ones need him more than the
afc teams because they understand what
they're going to be up against when it's
the titans the steelers the ravens are
the chiefs in the super bowl yeah i
agree i mean i i look at the seahawks
and packers i just don't think you're
going to be able to sit there and depend
on your defense you got to go all right
you know the strength is we're going to
win with our quarterback our offense you
know just like we saw again on on on
saturday or sunday with with green bay
the game doesn't fall the right way you
know that just they don't have enough
weapons to go around
and that's where they need another guy i
will say the ravens are another team
where you know i saw the comments
yesterday they were talking about the
bye week right they were gonna take time
to work on the passing game you know two
weeks ago when they played the bengals i
felt like they had a game where they
kind of were like we're gonna throw even
though we think we can run we're going
to work on the passing game i like that
they i think are another team that needs
i would like to see them dabble in the
wide receiver conversation because
again they get in the playoffs with the
chiefs and the titans
they're not going to be able to just
think we're gonna steamroll these team
and run them over there's no way the
chief's got big physical dudes up front
they can hang in there with the ravens
up front as we've seen and they can make
it okay lamar you have to pass to beat
us so do the titans and that to me is
going to be the big question about the
ravens as we get in the playoffs if
somebody slows down that run game lamar
and his right arm and that passing game
help carrying them over in that one game
they need it and so far it's been no uh
through the lamar jackson era
and you know there was some public
jostling by guys like lamar jackson and
hollywood brown antonio's cousin to get
antonio on the team and i poked around
the edges of that a little bit i don't
think the the teams
right and i'm not so sure that lamar and
hollywood aren't just being courteous
hollywood still has to have a
relationship with his cousin but you
know the reality is you bring a guy in
who's gonna want the football i mean
that you you've got you've got to be
able to manage a guy who's going to come
in and want the football and
when
lamar
and hollywood are so much younger than
antonio and maybe inclined to defer to
him i don't know that that's the right
way to go yeah i guess you need a spot
like tampa where tom brady 10 years
older plus than antonio brown and has
that relationship that they forged very
quickly during his limited time in new
england whatever that relationship is if
antonio brown is going to be deferential
to tom brady i think that's going to
work wherever antonio brown goes
he needs to be willing to defer
he needs to be on a one-strike situation
and he needs to not feel emboldened to
behave the way he did in pittsburgh or
the way he did with the raiders because
that's one of the reasons why he's in
his current predicament chris yeah no
exactly right it it you know i i'm
hopeful hopeful that he's turned his
life around and he can maybe get out
there and play it's been a tough
situation it really has and it's been a
little unfair to him in a lot of ways so
uh we'll see but yeah that's gonna be
interesting with some teams needy for
wide receivers
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports